vous le savez très bien parce que vous
m'avez soutenu les quelques jours après
la demande en mariage on était
extrêmement violent avec une déferlante
de commentaires après je m'en étais
expliqué ici surtout pour fatou de ma
responsabilité et je suis émue au moment
d'en parler donc le prix à payer avait
été violent parce que dans ces cas là
vous déchaîner des passions d'alors
encore une fois peut-être que ce que
j'ai fait était maladroit c'est pas le
problème mais le déchaînement avait été
hyper compliqué et heureusement vous
étiez là le week-end et après vous étiez
là tout le temps pour en parler parce
que vous savez pas comment gérer mais
simplement ce que se disent et les
critiques sont violentes mois se parler
de la médiatisation je pense que dans
ces cas là il faut rester dans sa
coquille il passe à arrêter au mobile
non j'ai pensé que
j'ai pensé que excusez moi j'ai pensé
que le soutien que vous apportiez dans
ces cas-là avait été vraiment nécessaire
pour fatou et moi il équilibre du couple
et vous savez pas à quel point ça avait
été un proche vous savez pas à quel
point ça va être important moi
c'était compliqué parce que c'est
violent et en fait moi franchement moi
je m'en fous totalement je peux tout
prendre je m'en fous c'est hyper violent
sur les réseaux parfois ce que je dis je
le mérite mais c'est pour elle pour
l'entourage elle n'avait rien fait rien
demandé et c'est l'entourage qui est
dans ces cas là qui subit voilà donc
merci bernard mémoires récemment j'ai
été très violemment attaqué sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que j'ai été très
mal compris sans doute j'ai du mal à
exprimer j'avais pas l'habitude du tout
de ressorts autant de violence je reçois
que la gentillesse mais là parce que je
défends des la présomption d'innocence
parce que j'aurais dû dire que je crois
les plaignantes évidemment donc je le
redis que je défends les femmes qui sont
mal à vous a vraiment oui parce que
quand on est mal compris c'est
l'injustice si vous voulez là du coup
vous vous leviez mal et j'ai mal vécu
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses pour ça que
j'ai bloqué les commentaires
actuellement toujours actuellement
encore mais c'est extrêmement violent
moi je bois qui défend justement ce
combat et je croit les plaignants parce
qu'il faut croire les plaignants que ça
avait beaucoup évolué et heureusement et
que maintenant les écoutes et en
revanche je défends aussi la
présentation des mathieu on en parle et
c'est vrai que quand on est connu franck
fondamentale enfin gros mental d'acier
mais vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
que j'arrêtais un nom est joué 10 bien
sûr je voulais faire du cinéma tous
avantageux pas rêver mais il y avait une
fatigue nerveuse ça c'est sûr et ça m'a
fait tellement de bien 7 année pour moi
oui pal et réussir -
après la polémique avec le rappeur j'ai
eu énormément de moi moi comme quand
bernard moi j'avais d'habitude j'ai eu
un peu bisounours moi j'avais vraiment
des flots d'amour et tout d'un coup j'ai
pas compris un déferlement de haine de n
y compris antisémite etc et je m'y
attendais vrai crack et de tout ça a été
vraiment très dur vous m'avez et vous
avez été d'un grand secours d'abord il
ya eu aussi même de la violence physique
qui était voilà et j'ai même eu un garde
du corps on m'avait même je donnais un
garde du corps pendant quelques temps ça
et moi ce qui m'a vraiment je suis un
peu ému ce qui m'a vraiment fait de la
peine c'est que ça fait de la peine à
mes parents
que je croise d'ailleurs que j'adore
voilà ils ont eu peur pour moi ouais
donc
on a encore des petites blessures quand
même hein c'est vrai mais je suis très
heureuse parce que vraiment les
téléspectateurs ont été absolument
adorable que hope rendre la distance et
on sait que c'est très ciblé et que
c'est une cyber attaque et que ça va
passer et donc c'est compliqué ce que
tout le monde sait que c'est pas nous
bien sûr nous on sait qu'on est fort
mais que c'est pas un problème on fait
de la télé c'est pas très grave mais en
revanche quand ta maman a peur voilà
c'est autre chose
dans un sacré mental c'est vrai c'est
bon mathieu tu le dis c'est surtout
qu'en plus en plus entre guillemets la
nouvelle génération de tv rites et tout
ça c'est ce que disait ilan corps sur le
jo ils sont nés les réseaux sociaux ils
sont nés avec jennir cc flot de haine et
tout ça mais bernard
valérie ou même moins on n'est pas né
que les réseaux sociaux quand on a fait
ce métier on n'avait pas on n'était pas
prêts entre guillemets à ça et c'est ces
réseaux sociaux cette cette haine qui
arrive elle est très violente et en plus
il faut quand même préciser dans ce
genre d'émission très vite on oublie les
caméras on est entre nous mais comme
nous un dîner entre potes et parfois on
veut faire un bon mot parce qu'on dirait
et moi je vais faire un bon mot et la
blague c'était belge du coup j'ai répété
mais c'était comment vous comment vous
diriez vous vous apprendriez à un enfant
comment on fait les enfants voilà
j'avais dit une connerie j'avais à
propos de mon neveu mais mon dieu c'est
toute ma vie et le lendemain mais j'ai
eu un nombre de téléphoner et mon ami
fogiel qui m'aident il faut il faut que
tu fasses a démenti faut que tu
t'excuses ça part dans tous les sens est
ce un tsunami et on sait pas comment
gérer ça on n'a pas fait ce métier pour
ça on a pas d'étude de crise on n'est
pas un homme politique on n'a pas des
gens y viennent pour gérer des crises
exactement les mêmes reproches dans ces
cas là aussi un double vraiment de vos
proches et 2 2 absolument
absolument les proches et les clips qui
est la national art vous et tout ça mais
c'est vrai que wee cc c'est très violent
mais regardez les ricoh va servir je
suis désolé c'est très très bien et
merci à tous et et spectateurs qui ont
été absolument adorable
[Applaudissements]